Trump attorney, Rudy Giuliani's indicted henchman
left harness, said that people around Trump
are going to continue to deny knowing him.
And as they continue to do that, he going
to start releasing
documents and audio visual evidence confirming
that they actually do know him.
And so far he's sticking to his word Lev Parness
his attorney leaked a video showing him hanging
out with Mike Pence and Pence, his wife holding
her hand just after Mike Pence insisted he
doesn't know love Parness.
Now there are caveats here, which we will
get to, but this is delightful.
Let's take a look at the video here.
We will play it without audio because the
video has copy-written music on it.
And if the YouTube algorithm were to pick
up on me playing someone else's music, we
would be immediately penalized as terrible,
terrible people that we are.
Uh, but what you can see in the video is love
Parness holding hands with Karen Pence.
Mike Pence, his wife, chatting with her.
Mike Pence is next to her, uh, talking to
someone else at the table and the video cuts
off and loops as a Mike Pence kind of gets
ready to shift over in the direction of, of
love.
Parness.
Now we don't yet have the full details about
this encounter, but of course what we do know
is that all of these people are lying about
not knowing love.
Parness and I'll catch you up from the beginning.
Donald Trump hired Rudy Giuliani as his personal
attorney.
One of the things Rudy Giuliani did was get
ambassador Maria Bonovitch quote out of the
way for Donald Trump.
And he partially did that with the help of
two henchmen love Parness and Igor Fruman,
both of whom have since been indicted Fruman
not visibly cooperating.
Parness very much cooperating with documents
and files and testimony and recordings.
For a while.
There have been Republicans who have been
insisting, we don't know the guy.
Most recently we had a documents revealed
that show Lev Parness was involved in putting
physical surveillance on ambassador Marie
Evanovich, which is absolutely insane for
the henchmen of a president's personal attorney
to be doing.
And it was also confirmed that despite Congressman
Devin Nunez insisting I have not had no contact
with loved partners, loved Parness and Devin
Nunez did communicate by phone this panicked
everybody around Donald Trump, they started
scrambling to say left left partners who,
who, but I don't know the guy no idea who
you're talking about.
Earlier this week in a video that now has
nearly 200,000 views, we showed you pictures
of love Parness with everybody, with Donald
Trump, with Jared Kushner, with Ivanka Trump,
Kellyanne Conway, Mike Pence, Eric Trump,
Don jr, the whole gang.
Now once again, even talking to Mike Pence
and Karen Pence at some kind of event, it's
not proof that they were friends with Lev
Parness, but there's clearly recognition here.
Parness is holding hands with Karen Pence.
This is not a perfunctory hi, nice to meet
you.
That sometimes happens at fundraisers or other
events.
They know each other.
So here's the deal with Parness.
He's been indicted, he's been charged with
crimes.
He's a henchman who's done lots of dirty work
for Rudy Giuliani and likely for others.
We should not put our unmitigated trust with
a guy who is now back against the wall and
desperate to do whatever he can to get out
of trouble.
But Parness is doing what he said he would
do.
He says he has the goods and that he would
release them.
He's doing it.
It's an absolute pleasure to see him releasing
exhibit after exhibit of evidence linking
himself to the people who continue to claim.
They just have no idea who this guy is.
Mike Pence is a liar and I thought that these
Dominionist evangelical Christians like Mike
Pence, aren't they not supposed to lie or
is it okay to lie?
If you can justify it somehow and say, well,
the, the, the ends justify the means here
or something like that.
Pence is lying.
They're all lying and I hope love partners
continues to one little a bit at a time expose
that they know him.
Now the, the separate question of course is
what's going to happen in the Senate impeachment
trial.
We talked about this yesterday.
We talked about it a little bit at the top
of the show today.
Uh, Republicans in the white house are desperate
to prevent left Parness from testifying at
all with John Bolton.
It seems as though they're recognizing he
probably will testify and maybe they can get
it to happen behind closed doors with love
Parness they are going to argue that he is
not a material witness.
That what he knows and what he would testify
to would not materially affect the outcome
or understanding of the facts and evidence
by the jurors.
In this case, 100 senators, that's obvious
BS.
This guy clearly has the goods and he should
testify and we'll see if Democrats can force
it to happen because Democrats are up against
a Republican majority intent on preventing
it from happening.
We'll see a good for Lev Parness for continuing
to release
this stuff.